garder son sang froid aujourd'hui le
déconfinement est malheureusement un
échec il faut le constater
et encore une fois sans polémique il
faut essayer de chercher les raisons de
cet échec qui va impacter 67 millions de
français dès demain soir probablement
donc dans ce cadre là ce que je dis à
monsieur vers ans et que bien sûr et il
n'est pas le seul responsable ou non
n'est pas le seul responsable est un
échec collectif mais néanmoins il est
membre du gouvernement et le
gouvernement doit gouverner donc doit
assumer ses décisions et des décisions
n'ont pas été prises au bon moment et je
pense que notamment depuis le 11 mai
beaucoup de mesures auraient pu être
prises y compris son plan social pour
accompagner les français mais on a
l'impression que le miz de la santé
finalement refus cette responsabilité de
l'arrivée de la deuxième vague il dit
c'est un phénomène européen qui tish qui
touche tous les pays même les bonnes et
les bons élèves madame rossignol a eu
raison de rappeler que le 14 juillet
présent d'un public avait dit mais nous
serons prêts en cas de deuxième vague
manifestement on ne l'est pas et cette
comparaison avec les autres pays
européens
me choque pas mal je vais vous le dire
pourquoi parce que ceux d'hier mais
finalement quand on se regarde quand on
se compare on peut se consoler mais moi
ce que je demande c'est que mon pays
soit meilleur que les autres pays
européens et donc qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché c'est nous qui amène à ce que
nous soyons obligés de nous re combiné
dès demain soir probablement est-ce que
vous allez voter la confiance après le
discours du premier ministre
jean castex demain après midi vous me
posez une question d'alchimiste parce
que finalement vous savez ce qu'il
voyait maintenant ce discours je ne le
sais pas on espérait qu'il nous
donnerait des éléments hier soir dans la
grande réunion avenue de ségur ça n'a
pas été le cas
nous sommes restés sur notre faim et mon
objectif c'est bien sûr d'abord
d'écouter ce sport le président la
république
et curieusement d'avoir ce débat 50-1
après alors qu'une si nous avions eu
avant nous aurions pu avoir des
explications de la part de trois
ministres donc on nous prend en otage et
je ne veux pas que le parlement sur la
voiture balai du gouvernement
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup patriquin
[Musique]